I always like to just remind you that
the sixth it's kind of an assignment but
the numbers we're gonna do this news
brief project where it's a teamwork
project if you choose if you take a look
at the the piece set that you have in
your hands now it asks you for a little
bit of information on that who you're
gonna be working with if you choose to
work with someone you can work on your
own that's fine and we're looking to get
a news brief that's of significance to
research going on in the life sciences
and I've given you there are a couple of
links in the sidebar of the website to
good places where you can find
interesting material what I'm super
interested in for you as a group where
many of you are in the engineering
fields is to find something really cool
at the interface between the life
sciences and engineering where
engineering has a huge impact on the
life sciences you have alternatives you
can download the coordinates of a
protein and print it on a 3d printer and
give us a summary of what the protein is
what it does and submit your 3d print
I'll give it back to you afterwards once
we've had a look at it but actually
submit the 3d print and then the other
opportunity is I think you'll remember
back to when we were talking about
molecular biology of the cell I did kind
of a clunky demo at the front of the
class nothing like Professor Martin
stammers at all this was me with the
ethernet cables showing you what
topoisomerase did but in my demo I
didn't show you how topo also cuts a
strand of DNA holds it while the ants
super coiling unwinds and then stitches
it together so I thought some of the
engineers might be able to come up with
something that was really better than
that for me to use for us to use next
year in class so that's a real time
really laying down the challenge there
so I always like things in the news I
thought this was kind of interesting
that the first vertebrates evolved in
shallow waters I thought those were
really cool first vertebrates I'd love
to get one of them in a fish tank and
keep it but anyway that's
that's fact it's it's truly amazing what
you can see in the science reports news
briefs I look at them whenever they come
in I get the posts every two or three
days and then I'm kind of pleased to see
that there's a lot of things that are in
those news briefs that I feel that we're
enabling you to read with some
appreciation because of what we're
covering in the class so what we're
doing now is we're really taking a leap
forward here into cells and organisms
with respect to understanding how
structure and function of individual
macromolecules proteins nucleic acids
sugars determine life determine the
dynamics of life that are necessary for
an organism to really go through a life
cycle divide have cells divide go
forward have cells move so what we're
going to be talking about in the next
lectures which is Section six is
cellular trafficking and signaling and
so for the first lecture which is 19
that we're on now so we're past the
midway mark I'm going to be talking
about trafficking and that is how within
a cell things get to where they need to
be or they get exported from a cell
because all of the actions of a cell are
really like thinking about the cell as a
circuit board where there's a receiver
that gets information and then as the
complex circuitry determines what
outcome you get at the end of the day so
many of the proteins that we've talked
about need to be in specific places for
the cell to function we have to have DNA
polymerase in the nucleus it's not going
to be useful in the cytoplasm we have to
have a transcription factor that helps
transcription go to the nucleus at the
right time for transcription to occur
but we don't want it there all the time
because otherwise you'd have the light
switch on the entire time that wouldn't
be useful so we need to regulate where
certain macromolecules are we need to
have the
heba's on the surface of the cell to
receive signals from outside this is not
just pertinent for multicellular
organisms it's pertinent for unicellular
organisms for them to sense their
environment know what's going on around
them is the salt concentration changing
is it getting very hot is it getting
cold
is there enough oxygen even unicellular
organisms need to receive signals and
responds to them multicellular organisms
are way more complicated because they
you need to establish organs and
different parts of a multicellular
organism that have specialized function
so trafficking really is about what
happens after you've made a replicated
DNA in the Mook in the nucleus
transcribed it made a mature messenger
that goes out to the cytoplasm in most
cases we'll talk about the exception to
that case and then in the cytoplasm when
proteins are expressed all the different
things that happen that guarantee that
the protein gets to a proper destination
for function and though some of those
are quite complicated because remember
if I'm going to park a receiver in the
cellular membrane with the signals being
captured from outside I've got to get
from the cytoplasm out there in a
reliable ways in lectures 20 20 and 21
I'll talk to you about cellular
signaling with a focus on mammalian
cells and the sorts of signaling
processes that may go awry in cells for
example proliferating cells and then
professor Martin will really focus in on
neuronal cells and opto genetics in
lecture 22 so this bundle really allows
you to call in the things that you've
learned until now and apply them into
much more intriguing and complex
situations so here's a wonderful sort of
silly drawing of a triangular cell
there's always a joke in cell biologists
when they're trying to talk well when
you're they're trying to talk to
mathematicians and mathematicians want
to simplify everything and so everything
gets imagine a cell and there's this box
shows up on a screen well we all know
that
don't hunt triangular or box shaped but
nevertheless I thought this one was
particularly cool and so trafficking the
process of trafficking is really all
about how where is the information
encoded into the protein that ensures
that the protein is where it needs to be
for the dynamics that we observe in
limit living system we've talked a lot
about static things we make the protein
here's the protein the protein folds we
talked a lot about things that are kind
of fixed in time and space but what we
want to do is understand what makes a
Cell programmed to undergo a new
function for example something as simple
as cell division we have to orchestrate
a very huge variety of activities in
order for the cell division process to
start to occur
something is really simple as cell
mobility think about how the cells move
they're not moving all the time but
sometimes they will move towards a
signal what triggers that kind of
interactions so in looking at the cell
these are some of the older images where
certain organelles for example are
stained so that you can see them so
peroxisomes aware degradation happens
the Golgi and ie
are a part of what's known as the
endomembrane system you'll see a lot
about this towards the end the later
part of the class where we talk about
how things get outside the cell in
through the endomembrane system there's
the surface plasma membrane the
cytoplasm is this sort of not really
aqueous it's an open space but it really
isn't open it's highly congested with
all kinds of molecules all kinds of sort
of structural proteins and so on so
don't think of the cytoplasm as a
solution but think of it as a much more
gel like structure with a lot of things
happening in it
the nucleus itself is also surrounded by
a membrane as is the endomembrane system
so this would be the nuclear envelope
within the nucleus you have a structure
called the nucleolus where aspects of
the nucleic acids necessary for protein
biosynthesis are made then there are
structural proteins like microtubules
and actin but now in this day and age we
don't have to deal with these vanilla
images we can actually use the methods
that you've learned about in the last
section recombinant biology to create
new versions of proteins that have along
with their sequence a marker that gives
them a fluorescence colored marker so we
are later on in the semester going to
spend three lectures on fluorescence and
cellular imaging well you'll learn more
about these fabulous proteins beyond
just saying we've got a green one and a
red one we're gonna give you all the
background on the protein engineering
that enabled those to become tools for
biology but for now I'm just going to
show you how much more interesting the
images of the subcellular structures are
when you've labeled for example a
particular protein that goes exclusively
to the nucleolus with a blue fluorescent
protein or to the mitochondria remember
professor Martin told you we always
think of these as and I'm not gonna do
the push up I'm just gonna say it right
powerhouse of the cell right I'm not I'm
not great with push ups to be honest but
you see these sort of more tangled
extended structures the maintain is a
more of a structural protein here at the
golgi the endoplasmic reticulum and the
nucleus so the colored fluorophore
proteins or the fluorescent chlorophyll
proteins actually allow us in real time
to observe dynamics once a protein is
made where does it go if we add a
trigger to the cell to cause an
interaction can we observe that protein
for example migrating to the plasma
membrane can we watch proteins being
made through the ER a variety of
different things that allow us in modern
biology to really look at bio dynamics
not just static informations and so what
I'm going to talk to you about is the
way
in which proteins are coded very early
on in their Genesis in their bio Genesis
in order to go to certain localized
certain locales within the cell so let
me just give you a bit of a road map
here with a protein and where things may
start so we have some options do we want
to send the protein outside the cell or
keep it inside the cell obviously too
big default differences if you're going
to go to a particular venue inside the
cell we going to just stay in the
cytosol that's sort of simple actually
that is the default position because you
want to remember that most proteins are
made on ribosomes in the cytosol of the
cell but the statistics are that about
50% of proteins end up somewhere else
than the cytoplasm they may end up in an
organelle back in the nucleus on the
surface or secrete it so there's a lot
so it's a good solid 50% that don't end
up staying in the cytosol where they
were originally made their alternative
is to go to organelles and if you'll go
into an organelle remember the ribosome
is not membrane doesn't have a membrane
perimeter but many of the organelles do
have membrane perimeters so we're
talking here about the mitochondria
it is hot you long of the word the
nucleus so I'm going to abbreviate
things like peroxisomes or various
membrane bordered organelles where we're
going to have to figure out if something
is made in the cytoplasm how does it get
into those organelles now we've spoken a
little bit about the fact that some
proteins are made in the mitochondria
I'm gonna get back to that in a moment
but all the proteins in the mitochondria
are not made in the mitochondria some of
them are shipped in remember the theory
endosymbiotic theory where we said that
mitochondria may have originated from
bacteria and been engulfed into cells
those bacteria obviously were originally
self-sufficient but a lot of the
proteins that were expressed in the
mitochondria were dispensed with and
they were and mitochondria now use
proteins from that are encoded by the
nuclear DNA rather than the mitochondria
but to this day some proteins remain
encoded within the mitochondria so these
are opportunities where that may be and
I'm going to talk very specifically
about signals that can get proteins into
the mitochondria and into the nucleus
and it turns out that the barriers
around those organelles are pretty
different I'll come back to that in a
second when we get on the next slide
with respect to going outside the cell
there are two options one option is for
the protein to remain in the plasma
membrane but with part of its structure
outside the cell so the other option is
for the protein actually to be spit out
of the cell as a soluble entity that can
travel around an organism for example in
the bloodstream and go to a remote site
and that becomes very important in
signaling so we would call those
proteins secrete and soluble so these
would be membrane bound these would end
up being soluble proteins that's
take a look at the structure of the cell
and look at where these various
components are so if you see these dots
those are free ribosomes in the
cytoplasm they would start to express
different proteins a lot of proteins are
expressed in the ribosome but in some
cases proteins become expressed on
ribosomes that are associated with the
endoplasmic reticulum and therefore you
start a process whereby proteins end up
being shipped to the outside of the cell
so where you see the speckles here the
free ribosomes and then the ribosomes
bound to the rough endoplasmic reticulum
here your destinies are on the
right-hand side of that picture and here
the destiny of these proteins ends up on
the left-hand side of this sort of
family tree that I'm showing you there's
obviously one more place where proteins
are made and that's in the mitochondria
and if you remember the first question
on your exam it described the DNA that's
in the mitochondria going back to the
endosymbiotic theory that's a circular
piece of DNA and it sets it apart and
the ribosomes in the mitochondria look
more like bacterial ribosomes than you
carry otic ribosomes so remember all
along we're gonna try in the second half
of the course to bring back knowledge we
taught you but sort of in a sense
endlessly remind you to keep the big
picture in mind because we've already
spoken to you about it so this now is a
nice pictoral
vision of what I've just described to
you and I'm going to first of all talk
about proteins that are made in the
cytoplasm and may be shipped to various
organelles and what that's and how
that's accomplished and then in the
second part of the class I'll talk about
how proteins are shipped to cell surface
offer expulsion from the cells okay so
the key mechanisms whereby proteins are
trafficked to new locations are first of
all using
targeting sequences the part of the
protein sequence and this is a very
common way in which proteins are
trafficked they're part of the sequence
they may be at the amino or the carboxy
terminus but they are woven into the
structure of your protein so your
protein comes along with a barcode
saying where it's going to necessarily
end up and for the nucleus mitochondria
Roxas homes for example people have done
extensive work with bioinformatics to
basically look at protein sequences and
find common themes of particular
sequences that may be common to where a
set of proteins may end up sometimes
those sequences may not be easy to see
just at first glance but now there are
websites that have you can very very
readily put your protein sequence into
the website and it will say it's got a
nuclear localization sequence or a
mitochondrial targeting sequence so we
can either do this by eye or we can use
informatics analysis informatics
analysis is very valuable because
sometimes information may be a bit more
encrypted and it may be a real struggle
to slog through a lot of sequences so
you can really find out about the
targeting sequence is so bioinformatics
because nowadays the genomes of dozens
and thousands of organisms are available
readily online and you can literally
pass out information from the genomic
information that gives you the proteomic
information so let's so that's one way
so with sequences that
targeted in some cases those targeting
sequences remain part of the protein but
in other cases in order to ensure that a
protein stays put the targeting
sequences are removed so that's another
important point you may keep the
targeting sequence or you may lose it
through the action of another enzyme
that cuts off the targeting sequence
when destination has been reached now
there's a second way that we can
understand program where a protein may
go and this is right these are rather
useful transformations that make things
even more dynamic so let me walk you
through sort of a concept if you think
of a protein that's made on the ribosome
it's got a targeting sequence in order
to get that protein to destination
you've got to make a new batch of
protein that's going to go to its
destination it's going to end up in the
mitochondria you've got to make the
protein de novo sometimes when we need
to have the action of a cell we can't
wait that long we can't do things
quickly in and expect the cell to
suddenly change it's a change what it's
doing because we're sitting around
waiting for the ribosome to make new
copies of the protein so the second way
in which proteins are targeted to new
destinations through what's known as
post translational modifications
this is so unfair Adam I saw you using
the middle boards but it looked so much
easier okay so the second way to target
a protein to a destination is using post
translational modifications what does
this mean what it means is that a
protein is made it's ready it's waiting
but we haven't engaged its final destiny
destiny
we haven't triggered it to go where it
needs to be but we're waiting for an
enzyme to just carry out a minor
a seemingly minor modification of that
protein and then the protein will go to
its destiny and I've shown you here
examples of three types of modifications
one we will talk about today because
it's very simple to understand
liquidation and then the other two we'll
talk about next time loss for relations
and ubiquitination and these are all
what are known as PTMs
post translational modifications and
they are changes that occur to an amino
acid side chain within an already made
protein to alter its destiny and I like
to talk about lipid ation first because
I can I get to remind you about cellular
membranes so remember we've talked about
these semi permeable barriers that are
around organelles and around cells and
let's say that this is a membrane kind
of that exists between the cytoplasm and
the outside of a cell and let's say I
have a protein lurking around in the
cytoplasm but I need it at the membrane
I needed to get involved in a signaling
process and I need it now to be there
if I have a soluble protein it's not
associated with the membrane but I can
use another enzyme to attach a
hydrophobic resi tail to that protein so
what it really wants to do is to get to
the hydrophobic membrane lipid ation is
such a modification it's just the
modification with a long chain often C
16 C 18 fatty acid that then renders the
protein lipophilic and makes it want to
move and it served its lipophilic tail
into the membrane and parked the protein
of the plasma membrane so the
information is still though encoded
within the protein how could how could
that happen
what could how could I have made that
information be in the protein what what
what might be the strategy there is
still encoded but it's secret its
cryptic any ideas so I'm not going to
just glom this group onto a protein I'm
going to put it somewhere specific and
so oftentimes liquidation reactions
occur sites Alex site specifically a
particular sites within a sequence and
an enzyme recognizes that sites and
transfers the lipid ik molecule to it so
lipid ation actually may occur for
example at the amino terminus of a
protein but if there are certain
features within that protein you may
then attach the lipid ik group so once
again using bioinformatics you can look
at a target protein of interest and
predict that it's the target of a post
translational modification reaction so
once again the information is programmed
into the sequence but it's quite cryptic
it could be within the middle of the
sequence there could only maybe be a
couple of clues but the clues are there
nonetheless that can be passed out using
computer learning and screening of
sequences to say that is a target for
lipid
Asian or phosphorylation or such so does
everyone and is that clear to people
does that make sense the information is
encoded but you can't see that it's
there but the advantage of the post
translational modifications is that they
occur on demand as opposed to making a
new protein de novo and then having it
go to a particular cellular location
later on when we talk about
phosphorylation you will see that
phosphorylation is the bread and butter
of cellular signaling it's the light
switch in every room in the cell that
turns on and off
in order to make functions happen within
the cell and that's a really major
dynamic post translational modification
that has significant meaning okay so the
reason on this little image I just
wanted to show you the membrane and just
to remind you that the membrane is a
super molecular structure that's
assembled with a hydrophobic core and
polar head groups on both faces as I've
sort of indicated in this cartoon so
let's start with sequences that might
take us to the nucleus now the nuclear
membrane is rather a strange entity
because the nuclear membrane isn't a
simple membrane like the plasma membrane
it's actually a double layer two
membrane so if you look at a nuclear
membrane and I'm just gonna do a a job
of showing a portion of the nuclear
membrane within the nuclear membrane
there are pores quite large openings and
the membrane is actually a double
membrane where all of these are lipid
bilayers so it's not a single membrane
it's a double membrane
with large openings you might say well
that's no use there's just these great
big gaping holes in the nucleus anything
can come and go if it wants but the
nuclear pores are kind of a special
structure because they have a protein
that's kind of disordered that creates a
tangled network that means that that
pore isn't totally open but there's some
stuff that something's got to get
through to get from one side to the
other and my colleague Thomas Schwartz
in biology works on the macro molecular
structure of nuclear pores to understand
these structures because these are also
made through the auspices of having a
lot of proteins that help create this
structure otherwise that membrane
wouldn't stay in its proper format so in
order for a protein to get into the
nucleus if it needs to or leave the
nucleus it has to have some kind of
mechanism to get through this structure
that's plugging the nuclear pore so this
would be the inside of the nucleus this
would be the cytoplasm so as shown on
this slide the nucleus there's a
particular protein sequence that's
appended to your protein that's node is
the nuclear localization sequence or NLS
modern NOLs sequences it's a short
sequence of amino acids that enables a
protein to get to its proper destination
and these sequences are quite well
recognized they may end up being highly
basic sequences so an example of an air
less would be lice it's not very
exciting but it just goes on like slice
slice arginine lysine and it may be
bounded by hydrophobic residues or other
types
that would be a typical nls sequence
that's in a protein and I want to remind
you that lysine and arginine all have
side chains that at physiological pH are
positively charged so the nucleolus
localization sequence is something
that's easily recognized because of this
sort of short sequence that may be at
the NR C terminus I think there's either
possibility but it's a very clear
sequence you could look at your protein
sequence see there's an NL s on that
sequence and it's the NL s sequence
alone that's responsible for getting the
proteins in and out of the nuclear pore
let's mostly focus on getting into the
nucleus basically you have a protein
structure it has an NL s sequence at one
terminus and that NL s sequence binds to
another protein it creatively you had a
little bit of chance to give proteins
names in the exam
it's called important so it's an import
protein the binds to the NL s and as a
consequence of that will carry cargo it
will escort cargo into the nucleus of
the cell and it sends it through this
meshwork of proteins that's a very loose
meshwork of proteins but not ordered
proteins they're highly disordered
proteins so they make more of a filter
than a plug but they are definitely
something that doesn't allow any old
protein to go through that nuclear pores
and they're less tags are very easy to
recognize once again through
bioinformatics analysis and what's
really cool is that you can reprogram a
protein to be where you want by
manipulating the NL s so this is rather
a nice set of experiments let's say we
have a protein that we're going to micro
inject into the cytoplasm of the cell
and we want to program it to either go
into the nucleus or stay outside the
nucleus
that can be done readily by attaching a
nuclear localization sequence to a
protein along with a fluorophore
dye or fluorescent protein that will
allow you to observe that experiment if
you micro inject into the cytoplasm that
protein that's gotten nls will get run
into the nucleus through association of
the NLS with important but if you chop
that NLS off the protein is stuck
remains out in the cytoplasm let's say
you want to study a new protein i just
want to show you that these NLS sequins
are totally independent of the cargo
they carry you can just stick an nls on
your favorite protein do you want to
interrogate let's take pyruvate kinase
doesn't have anything to do with
specific transport to the nucleus but
nevertheless if you put if it doesn't
have an nls it's fluorescently labeled
it stays outside in the cytoplasm but if
you put an NL s on it you concentrate
into that region of the cell so these
experiments show you that what we know
about these targeting sequences can be
manipulated and used to enable you to
move things around in the cells that's
one particular type of mechanism the
next mechanism i want to describe to you
is the mechanism that's used for
mitochondrial transport and it's still a
little bit different in its strategy so
to get into mike the mitochondria there
is again a recognition sequence in this
case a mitochondrial localization
sequence that has particular
characteristics in this case the
mitochondrial localization sequence say
it's the end terminus of your protein
and it would be something that might be
a mix of charges some are glue or
glue so that's a typical MLS sequence
and in this case the the charge at
physiological pH is different from the
nuclear localization sequence because
it's an alternating positive and
negative charge so this is pretty
different from this we it doesn't think
bioinformatics to figure that one out so
you can then pick out mitochondrial
localization sequences and so in this
case remember mitochondria make some of
their own proteins on their circular DNA
but they've abandoned expressing all the
proteins that are needed in the
mitochondria and some proteins are
transported into the mitochondria using
these types of sequences but the
approach the strategy is different from
getting into the nucleus in this case
the protein the MLS sequence associates
with a protein channel that is in a
closed State so here's a membrane here's
the makings of a channel but it's in a
closed state but once the protein with
the nls sequence binds to that that
channel opens it's triggered by the
binding of that sequence to an extra
portion of the protein that's outside
that membrane and that then allows the
protein to be unfolded and transported
into the mitochondria where that
sequence may be removed and then protein
refold in the mitochondria so it's a
very different strategy for them for
that in the nuclear localization
sequence so you'll find for many
different organelles in the cell there
might be very specific localization
sequences that you could look up and
learn about but one thing I want to
mention to you is that these
localization details are very important
and many diseases in cells are a
consequence of proteins not being
localized to the right place if you're
not in the right place at the right time
then things will start to go wrong with
the signaling or the processes of the
cell so diseases are frequently low
associated with miss localization so now
what we're gonna do
it's basically say we've taken care of
understanding things made in the cell
they either stay in the cytosol or the
gota
organelles based on particular types of
strategies that are largely dependent on
short tagging sequences but in other
cases may be dependent on post
translational modifications all right so
here is a cartoon but actually I want to
do something slightly different if it
doesn't take too long now when we first
talked about translation on the ribosome
what you see there in green and yellow
is the ribosome the dark band is a
messenger RNA the dark blue transfer
RNAs that are being helped with
elongation factors to get to the
ribosome but what I want to point out
here is the emerging sequence of
polypeptide coming out through a tunnel
on the ribosome now if a protein is
going to be destined outside the cell it
is expressed with what's known as a
signal sequence it's about a 20 amino
acid residue sequence that is recognized
by the signal recognition particle and
then translation slows down and clamps
the ribosome on the endoplasmic
reticulum membrane so that the new
peptide starts being threaded into the
endoplasmic reticulum through what's
known as the translocon so you're now
not sending the protein out to the
cytoplasm but you're rather sending the
protein into the endoplasmic reticulum
and you're also sending it down this
branch of the of the protein
biosynthesis pathway you see this piece
of protein emerging this hatched portion
is the cytoplasm the gray portion is the
endoplasmic reticulum so there is a
complex machinery at play that enables
proteins to be made in the cytoplasm but
now targeted to a completely new
location and these are the proteins that
are going to be destined
to either stay in the plasma membrane or
be secreted from the cell and this view
here gives you a little bit more than
the cartoon so ribosome a signal peptide
is made that is a green peptide sequence
that's about 20 amino acids long that is
actually called a signal peptide it's
signaling for synthesis through the
endomembrane Network that causes the
ribosomes to dock down on the cytosol ER
membrane and keep on being synthesized
so the proteins are made into that
endomembrane system and you can think of
this cavernous membrane system as your
tunnels out of a cell for either display
on the surface of the cell or for
secretion entirely in vesicles so let's
take a look at how that occurs in that
when you make a protein in that way see
the the dark dots the rough ER these are
ribosomes that are attached to the
membrane proteins are made into the
membrane and then the endomembrane
system is not really just a tunnel or a
labyrinth but actually each of those
layers
spits off vesicles that fuse with next
layers to gradually make their way
outside of the cells so here you see
there are vesicles you're always keeping
proteins associated with membrane as you
go through the endomembrane system and
here is a vesicle that's got protein in
it it may the release it to the outside
of the cell or the protein may be
associated with the membrane of the
vesicle and stay parked in the plasma
membrane so I just want to give you one
one final slide where I talk about the
biogenesis of membrane proteins now this
is pretty complicated stuff because you
kinda have to remember what's inside and
out so I spent sort of more time than I
should of on this cartoon to kind of
show you which end of the protein ends
up outside the cell which inside the
cell and how you make multi Multi
membrane spanning protein so let's take
a look at this in detail now looking
here's the ribosome
here's the protein emerging if there's a
signal sequence there that ribosome dots
down on the membrane and starts
translating the protein amino terminus
first into the endoplasmic reticulum
we're all ok with that as synthesis
continues we may reach the stop codon on
the messenger RNA and what may happen is
that the protein may remain associated
with membrane the amino terminus will be
in the ER and the C terminus will remain
on the other side there are a number of
different configurations but if we want
to start to transport this protein to
the surface of the cell that will then
stay associated with membrane but not in
the form of the flat membrane that it
was delivered into but that membrane may
pinch off into a spherical vesicle but
you still have the C terminus outside
and the end terminus in sight that will
then work its way through the
endomembrane system and ultimately fuse
with the cytosol this is a really fun
part and then once it's fused with the
cytosol it has the option to be
displayed on the outside of the cell
while I you have a protein the end
terminus all is on the outside the C
terminus is on the inside so that shows
you the biogenesis are the cell surface
protein that's stuck in the membrane
through its membrane associated domain
if you're not gonna stay with the
membrane you can actually also simply
release this into the vesicle for
release of a soluble protein I will not
go through this but there are miraculous
steps that end up in the biogenesis of
multi transmembrane proteins because
each of those transmembrane domains gets
made in the translocon and gets shuttled
sideways and you start piling up
transmembrane domains that span the
membrane and in the next class we're
gonna see how useful these proteins are
in cellular signaling so those are very
important proteins to think about one
last thing so let's think about this for
either configuration
either post-translational modification
or using targeting sequences when do we
define where the proteins going to end
up when where's the information first
defined anyone want to answer me and
explain why yes
thus it's a it's a it's a good try but
you want to remember
yes splicing is important but where did
this when was the sequence actually in
the entire pre mRNA when would that have
been defined yeah sorry common yes
because you never have information in
the RNA that wasn't in the DNA so the
DNA's got the information there yeah it
may need a bit of splicing to put things
in the right place but the information
is there in the DNA so you want to
remember for all of this targeting
information it's in our it's in the
genomic information most commonly it's
the genomic information that has the
patterns of sequences for post
translational modification is the
genomic information that has things like
n LSE's and MLS's
they're already there but they are often
encrypted and there was a very nice
point there though if you want to send
to make a single chunk of a genome that
encodes either a protein that's going to
be exported through the secretory
pathway or stay in the cytosol you might
splice in or out a signal sequence so
that's a really good way using the same
original DNA sequence to actually get
two proteins that fulfill different
final destinies within the cell so next
time we're going to talk about signaling
it's going to be a blast okay
you